>> Alright, so now we're ready to dive in and actually work out some
math that turned out not to be so bad, but it was, it ends
up being okay specifically because we were
very carefully about setting up all the
definitions to lead us to this moment in time. It is our destiny, Charles.
>> Oh good. I love destiny. Is this destiny's theorem?
>> No, actually turns out it's Haussler's Theorem.
>> Is Haussler like German for destiny? It
might be, but I don't think it is. So,
Hausser is the name of a person in this
particular case. And what he worked out is a
way of bounding the true error as a function
of the number of training examples that are drawn.
>> Oh. Nice.
>> So, let's consider. From the hypothesis
set that we have, all the hypotheses can
be categorized as to whether or not they have high true error or low true error.
>> Sure.
>> Right so, let's let H1 through HK be
the ones that have a priority of high true error.
What we'd like to do is make sure that as we're
drawing data sets that we have knocked all these guys out.
We've gotten enough examples that actually allow us to verify that
they have high error. So they have high error on the, on
the training set. So they have high training error. Alright, so
how many, how much data do we need to establish that
these guys are actually bad? Alright, so let's take a look
at the probability that if we draw an X, an input from
this distribution D. That, for any of these hypotheses.
Hi, and this set of bad hypotheses. That it will
match the true concept, right? So that H sub I of X is equal to C of X. And
we know that that's less than or equal to
one minus epsilon. It's unlikely that they match. Because it's
likely, or relatively likely, that they mismatch. Right? That's what
this exactly means. This, this error being greater than epsilon.
>> Oh, I see, so if I have an error of
greater than epsilon, that means that the probability that I'm wrong is
greater than epsilon, which means the probability that I'm right is
one minus epsilon, less than one minus epsilon. Okay, that makes sense.
>> Yeah, so it's sort of a relatively low probability of match.
>> Well, if epsilon is high.
>> Low relative to one minus epsilon.
>> Right, okay.
>> So this is,
this is a fact about the hypothesis in, in
the abstract. For any given sample set we've got a
set of m examples, and what we'd like to know
is, since we're trying to knock it out, what's the
probability that even after we've drawn m examples that this
hypothesis, h of i, remains consistent with c. Right, even
though the data doesn't really match all that well, we've
drawn M examples, and it still looks like it matches.
It's still in the version space. So the probability that
that happens if it were the case that everything was independent
is going to be one minus epsilon raised to the M
power. Right. Because it's less than one minus epsilon to be
wrong once Well, which is to say, that your consistent
ones. To continue to be consistent, we keep having to have
this probability come true. So, it's going to be, we're going
to just keep multiplying it in again and again and again.
So one minus epsilon raised the the m power.
>> Right. So that makes sense because
you're basically saying it's Consistent with the
first example and the second example and the third example and dot dot dot
nth example. So, and with independent variables
is just multiplication so it's one minus
epsilon times, one minus epsilon times, one
minus epsilon n times. Okay, I see that.
>> Great.
Alright, so can we use that to figure out
what's the probability that at least one of these h1
through hk's is consistent with c on m examples.
We have to knock them all out. That's...that's really what
the goal is. To knock out all the ones
that have high true error We failed at that. If
one of them still slips through, one of them still
looks consistent and remains in the version space. So what's
the probability that at least one of
these remains consistent. That this still has happened.
>> I think I know that. So just like you did add before and did
multiplication... Another way of writing at least one of is to say or.
So h1 or h2 or h3 or h4... or hk
is consistent. And just like and is multiplication, or is addition. That's true.
>> And
there are k different ones of these, so I have to
say this one minus epsilon to the m plus one minus epsilon
to the m plus one minus epsilon to the mk times
So that would be one minus epsilon to the m times k.
>> Great. So that is a bound on the probability that at least one of these
bad hypothesis is going to remain in the version space even after m examples.
But how many bad examples, how many bad
hypothesis are there? What's an upper bound on that?
>> Well, there might be one or there might be two. There's actually k of
them, but we know that k itself is bound by the total number of hypotheses.
>> Yeah, that's right. So it has to be, you know, the number of
bad hypotheses. We, we assume if c is equal to h anyway that there's
at least one that is not bad, but, you know, almost h of them
can be bad. So that, that should give us a bound. Alright, so now
we're going to to work on this expression a little
bit more to put it in a more convenient form.
>> Okay.